remember this
a time when khaki was cool and gap a
shopping staple
gap jeans once had such status they were
endorsed by missy elliot
and madonna now it's just another brand
shutting
its uk shops do you think it's changed
enough from this though
no that's the thing i think that is the
problem fashions now sold less by those
in ads and more
by those with influence leila is one
tens of thousands follow her fashion
tips
gap she says just hasn't changed with
the times
i think the first image that genuinely
comes into my mind when someone says gap
is 40 50 percent off everything signed
the red sign
and it's not really appealing i guess
when you know something is going to go
on sale it
automatically devalues the the the
visual impact in reading customers were
still coming
but this is one of 81 stores set to shut
gap will still have an online presence
but it isn't saying how many jobs will
be lost
is that understanding this will impact
in the region of
just over 2 000 employees within them
stores
that will end up losing the jobs it's
about time the government sat up
and looked at supporting the retail
sector
and as more shutters come down those
calls ramp up
debenhams and topshop's owner arcadia
just two that have recently been bought
by online giants
gap clearly struggled to remain relevant
enough to support
a high street presence but you don't
have to look very far up any shopping
street like this
to see the evidence of struggling bricks
and mortar retail
this isn't just about strategy it's
about fundamental shifts
in shopping habits those in real estate
say the only way to now avoid so-called
zombie high streets
isn't to replace but to change we've got
to accept that we've lost
you know a quarter of our spend already
um online that's probably not coming
back
but the high streets need to serve a
different and a broader function
gap has recently launched new lines
alongside rapper kanye west
this quintessentially american brand is
still pushing
but it no longer demands attention like
it once did
more of the same in the end not enough
helen and smith sky news reading